aujourd'hui madame Laurence boun
secrétaire d'État auprès de la ministre
de l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
qui est chargée de l'Europe pour qu'elle
rende compte à notre commission de la
dernière réunion du du Conseil européen
qui s'est tenu les 14 et 15 décembre
2023 je tiens à préciser que cette
réunion est vidéocapée sur le site du
Sénat et madame la ministre nous
recevons une délégation d'étudiants de
l'Université du Littoral de de Boulogne
sur mer qui sont étudiants en 2e année
de master de droit des
affaires évolution de l'économie donc je
sais que ce sont des sujets qui qui vous
intéressent beaucoup et et qui viennent
voir comment on travaille ici ici au
Sénat nous avions eu l'occasion de
débattre avec vous Madame la Ministre le
13 décembre au soir dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat et en amend de cette réunion qui
était lourde d'enjeu nous le savions je
vous avais notamment interpellé sur deux
sujets majeurs de son ordre du jour qui
était bien sûr l'aide à l' Ukraine et
l'élargissement l'abstention du Premier
ministre hongrois a finalement permis
d'ouvrir les négociations avec l'Ukraine
et la Moldavie et de reconnaître à la
Géorgie le statut de candidat c'est une
décision très engageante à tout point de
vue puisque à terme elle mettra l'Union
au contact direct de la Russie et
pourrait donc affecter directement sa
sécurité et puisqu'elle soulève aussi
des enjeux économiques majeurs notre
commission auditionnaé avanthier votre
collègue Marc fenau ministre de
l'Agriculture qui soulignait notamment
le défi que représente pour l'Union la
puissance agricole de l'Ukraine les
impératifs géopolitiques du moment
laissent de nombreuses questions dans
l'ombre et il est de notre
responsabilité de les mettre sur la
table surtout au vu de la récente étude
de l'EFCR European conouncil of foreign
relations qui atteste que seul 29 % des
Français sont favorables à l'intégration
de l'Ukraine dans l'Union concernant
l'aide à l'Ukraine unité se fissure
ostensiblement entre les États-membres
la Hongrie a opposé son véteau à
l'enveloppe budgétaire envisagée pour
pérenniser le soutien à l'Ukraine pour
empêcher sa défaite qui serait aussi la
nôtre visiblement la promesse de
déblocage de 10 milliards au titre de la
facilité pour la reprise et la
résilience n'aura pas suffi à acheter le
soutien
hongrois à acheter le le c'est le
président Orban qui qui
conteste qui nous écoute
ces marchandages en coulisse sont
paradoxaux pour assurer la défense de
ces valeurs bafouées à ses frontières
extérieures sur le sol ukrainien l'Union
se retrouve à transiger de manière
douteuse sur l'état de droit à
l'intérieur de ces frontières comment
éviter ce piège comment aussi éviter que
le 12iè paquet de sanctions adopté par
le Conseil européen soit contourné par
la Russie comme Vladimir Poutine l'a
aussitôt annoncé de manière provocatrice
là aussi la crédibilité de l'Union est
en jeu sa politique de sanction doit
porter des fruits sans quoi les peuples
européens ne voudront plus en payer le
prix enfin nous serions intéressés de
savoir quelle perspective se dessine
concernant la révision du cadre
financier pluriannuel nous venons de
l'évoquer en partie en évoquant le
le le PACT de stabilité pardon et aucun
accord n'a été trouvé une issue serait
espéré pour tout début février sur
quelle base la France a-t-elle identifié
de possibles redéploi budgétaire que la
Commission n'avait pas proposé ou
faudra-t-il raboter les lignes
budgétaires de certaines politiques
européennes et si oui
lesquelles serait dans le viseur à ce
stade enfin je relève que le Conseil
européen a confirmé la forte dynamique
impulsé par la Commission européenne en
matière de défense le rythme des
initiatives en la matière est soutenu la
commission annonce qu'elle présentera sa
stratégie industrielle pour l'Europe de
la défense et 10 dès février 2024 ainsi
qu'une nouvelle proposition pour un
programme d'investissement dans l'Europe
de la
défense alors que les derniers
règlements pour renforcer l'industrie
européenne de défense par des achat
conjoint et dire pasa et pour soutenir
la production de munition la zap
viennent tout juste d'être adopté et
vont être mis en œuvre en 2024 comment
se positionne la France à l'égard de
cette accélération en matière de défense
européenne je sais que tous ces sujets
sont larges parfois pointus mais madame
la ministre c'est un important que en
cette fin d'année on puisse avoir une
vision pour aborder les 6 mois à venir
de façon précise et clairire et je ne
doute pas que sur le pacte de stabilité
que nous venons de voir il y aura aussi
peut-être des questions complémentaires
c'est à
vous merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs sénateurs d'abord
merci de tenir ce cette réunion de de
contte-rendu auss près de la fin de
l'année je vous suis très reconnaissante
tente d'être d'être ici et vous avez
raison nous avions déjà discuté de la de
de l'ampleur de l'agenda de ce Conseil
européen et aussi de l'importance des
sujets qui étaient traités que ce soit
le soutien à l'Ukraine et
l'élargissement comme vous venez de le
mentionner la révision à mi-parcours du
cadre financier
plurannuel le conflit au Proche Orient
aussi les questions de sécurité de
défense j'ai je reviendrai je répondrai
à votre
question et puis bien sûr les
migrations un petit échange sur la COP
28 et la lutte contre les discours en
haine de haine pardon euh alors sur sur
l'élargissement je crois que le Conseil
a été à la hauteur puisque les décisions
ont été prises et comme vous le savez
d'abord la décision d'ouvrir les
négociations d'adhésion avec l'Ukraine
et la Moldavie vous l'avez mentionné la
Hongrie a fait le choix de
s'abstenir ce qui permet de préserver
l'unité des Européens puisque le
résultat du Conseil
l'engage même si elle n'est pas dans la
pièce c'est la une sorte d'absention
constructive je crois que c'était un
message politique très fort que nous en
avions discuté qu'il était nécessaire
d'envoyer à Moscou et ça rappelle aussi
le fait que l'Union européenne a
maintenant une vision géostratégique de
l'élargissement euh comme l'avait
exprimé le président de la République à
Bratislava à la fin du mois de mai c'est
aussi vous savez que nous avions eu de
nombreux échanges avec les Ukrainiens
avant ce conseil et je crois que c'est
un énorme message
d'espoir pour les autorités et pour le
peuple ukrainien puisqu'il Contin
continuent de lutter au quotidien contre
la guerre que leur mène les Russes et
puis c'est je crois le symbole de du
soutien sans faille que l'Union
européenne apporte à l'Ukraine depuis le
début de la guerre donc il y a également
eu au-delà de l'ouverture des
négociations
d'adhésion des messages pour réaffirmer
que l'Union européenne serait au côté de
l'Ukraine pour satisfaire les besoins
militaires pour des engagements
européens de sécurité pour des travaux
en cours aussi sur les avoir gelés dont
nous avions
discuté et en complément bien sûr de
l'aide bilatérale qui est apporté par
les
États-membres alors au-delà de l'Ukraine
il y a et de la
Moldavie le l'octroi du statut de pays
candidat à la Géorgie et là je tiens à
le dire sous réserve qu'elle metent en
œuvre les réformes nécessaires en
matière d'état de droit et ce qui est
important et comme on le voit je je vais
donner cet exemple la Macédoine du Nord
qui pour qui on a ouvert vers les
négociations d'adhésion depuis plus de
20 ans mais qui ne met pas en œuvre une
des réformes clés qui est son accord
avec la Bulgarie ne progresse pas sur le
chemin de l'adhésion donc c'est c'est
très clairement fondé sur des mérites en
matière d'état de droit d'abord puisque
les conditions pour ouvrir les
négociations d'adhésion pour l'Ukraine
et la Moldavie portaient essentiellement
sur l'état de
droit nous avons aussi envoyé un signal
clair et dans les mêmes lignes à la
Bosnie-Herzégovine puisque le Conseil a
répété que les négociations d'adhésion
seraient ouvertes lorsque les réformes
nécessaires auraient été mises en œuvre
donc là aussi un un
rappel vous aviez le 30 novembre dernier
nous en avions un peu parlé monsieur le
Président organiser une table ronde sur
l'élargissement de l'Union européenne et
notamment les questions de réforme
institutionnelle qui permettrait
d'éviter des blocages et peut-être nous
pourrons y
revenir alors c'est ça c'est aussi une
forte demande de de la France qui avait
été acceptée ou pour laquelle nous
avions convaincu les autres États qui
est que l'élargissement devrait être
accompagné d'une réforme de l'Union
européenne et en premier lieu une
réforme qui vise à adapter nos
politiques communes d'en revoir le
financement et bien évidemment la
gouvernance mais aussi la fonctionnalité
institutionnelle de l'Union
européenne je crois que c'est
extrêmement important on commence à avir
des chiffres sur ce que ça coûterait à
la politique agricole ou en matière de
politique de cohésion il faut bien avoir
en tête que ce ne sera pas les mêmes
priorités politiques pour cette Union
élargie et que nous préserverons les
intérêts bien évidemment des Français
dans ces négociations et pour se faire
le Conseil a demandé à la Présidence
belge du conseil de travailler à
l'adoption d'une feuille de route sur la
réforme de l'Union européenne d'ici
l'été 2024 je sais salaair techno mais
l'idée c'était d'ancrer de façon
politique la nécessité de revoir les
politiques de l'Union européenne leur
budget et leur gouvernance pour qu'elle
soit à la hauteur de ce qui nous attend
plutôt que de se précipiter juste pour
pour
élargir voilà il y aura aussi d'ici à
l'été prochain et céit une autre
discussion du Conseil l'adoption de
l'agenda stratégique pour la nouvelle
commission qui sera basée bien sûr sur
ce qu'on vient de dire euh mais qui qui
visera aussi à amplifier les décisions
qui avaient été prises dans sous cette
commission donc le plan de relance
européen la mutualisation d'achat des
vaccins le financement par l'Union
d'armes pour soutenir l'Ukraine et puis
ce changement de logiciel qui est
d'assumer une Europe souveraine donc
nous allons évidemment nous insister
beaucoup là-dessus puisque c'est la
prolongation de l'agenda de versaill qui
avait été adopté après l'invasion de
l'Ukraine par la
Russie
et pour tout cela nous avons évidemment
besoin de moyens financiers vous avez
mentionné la révision du cadre financier
plurannuel alors beaucoup de travail a
été fait cette semaine et les dernières
semaines pardon et et je crois qu'on est
abouti à peu près un équilibre qui a été
gelé pour
discussion lors du prochain conseil le
1er février
prochain évidemment la position de la
France cétait de trouver le bon
équilibre entre limiter la facture pour
les états membbr tout en assurant la
pérennité du financement des priorités
essentielles alors il y a une large
unanimité sur le soutien à l'Ukraine qui
est la priorité de tous les États
membres de l'Union européenne à travers
la
facilité il y a aussi et nous avons
beaucoup assisté là-dessus une priorité
accordé au fonds qui sont destinées aux
politiques migratoires à la fois de
gestion et de prévention et puis la
souveraineté technologique vous savez
que la France avait porté cette cette
idée de fond de souveraineté et qui va
rester dans le
CFP donc là je crois qu'on peut dire que
les positions de tous les États se sont
rapprochées nous étions très proches
d'un accord et donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle le Conseil était en mesure de
se réunir une nouvelle fois le 1er
février
2024 où nous espérons conclure même s'il
faut que ça prenne 4 jours comme en en
juillet 2020 ce que je ne souhaite à
personne euh mais nous saurons le
refaire évidemment si s'il le faut vous
avez parlé ensuite de la défense et
c'est quelque chose qui nous tient
beaucoup beaucoup à cœur d'abord vous
savez qu'on a lancé sous sous cette
mandature et en particulier sous la
présidence française de l'Union
européenne un effort industriel pour
renforcer nos capacités de production et
notre maîtrise des technologies de de
défense sur toute la chaîne
d'approvisionnement euh des armées
nous avons déjà la stratégie sur
l'industrie de défense qui est l'ED
ou plutôt elle est elle est pardon le le
Conseil a demandé à la Commission
effectivement de fournir quelque chose
en février là-dedans s'inscrira
l'instrument qui vise à favoriser à la
fois les investissements et les
acquisitions conjointes et ici je dois
peut-être insister sur le fait que le
Président de la République et nous
avions été avant dans les différentes
formes du conseil très insistant sur le
fait qu'il ne s'agissait pas de créer un
marché unique de la défense on est quand
même en train de parler de bien les Tau
mais un marché intégré qui nous permett
en fait d'avoir une meilleure défense
pour un coût moins élevé pour chacun des
États et c'est différent évidemment d'un
marché unique et puis ça nous permet
aussi de garder notre souveraineté en
matière de ce qu'on veut exporter et à
qui on veut l'exporter ce qui est très
important pour
nous il y a évidemment une discussion
sur la réforme de l'asile et des
migration vous avez vu que le le
Parlement européen est arrivé à un
compromis avec un
peu le Parlement européen est habitué à
faire des compromis on va on va dire les
choses comme ça je pense que c'est très
important pour les c'est à un accord qui
à la fois va nous permettre de mieux
maîtriser les flux migratoires les
frontières extérieures et de
préserver l'humanité qui convient pour
les demandeurs d'asile qui arrivve en
Europe
donc d'abord renforcer les frontières
c'est permettre de préserver la plus
grande réussite je crois de l'Union
européenne qui est la liberté de
circulation au sein pour tous les
citoyens au sein des 27 et on a une
politique d'asile et immigration qui qui
est à la fois plus juste et plus humaine
et plus efficace donc on renforce les
contrôles aux frontières extérieures
avec un système d'enregistrement
systématique et
sécurisé nous pouvons accueillir les
demandeurs d'asile avec la dignité qui
leur est dû parce que les demandes
seront traitées beaucoup plus rapidement
nous avons introduit de la solidarité
entre les
États-membres puisque chacun et pas que
les pays de première entrée
accueilleront des demandeurs d'asile et
puis les personnes qui n'ont pas
vocation à rester sur le territoire et
très souvent c'est des migrants
économiques donc ils doivent passer par
des filières économiques eux évidemment
ne quitteront le territoire plus
rapidement
euh voilà en parallèle nous continuons
les efforts sur les relations avec les
pays de départ et de
transit sur le proche orient vous savez
que les s'il y a convergence des
objectifs il y a pas nécessairement
convergence de toutes les positions sur
le sujet mais je crois que tout le monde
est d'accord pour évidemment la sécurité
d'Israël la paix et la sécurité de la
région la résolution de la crise
humanitaire à Gaza et puis la la défense
du droit international humanitaire euh
donc la France elle a rappelé la
priorité accordée à la libération
inconditionnelle des otages détenus par
le Hamas et évidemment je veux répéter
ici mes condoléances à la famille d'Éa
Toledano sur le plan humanitaire il y a
une plus grande convergence et surtout
comme il y avait des actions assez
bilatérales ce sur quoi le Conseil a
insisté c'est une coordination des
différentes initiatives humanitaires
pour qu'ell soit plus efficace euh est
plus rapide et donc ça c'est en cours et
sur le volet sécuritaire le président a
aussi proposé une coordination renforcer
des dispositifs pour la sécurité
maritime puisque vous avez nous avons
des bateaux là-bas donc don certains qui
ont détourné des drones qui ciblait un
navire norvégien mais il y a déjà les
dispositifs àalent et AG Nord donc
l'idée ici c'est effectivement de se
coordonner pour lutter contre le
terrorisme et puis puis tous les pays de
l'Union européenne sont d'accord sur une
solution à deux états et cela a
été
répété voilà je ne veux pas être trop
longue je crois qu'il y a juste deux
choses à mentionner sur la COP d'abord
le quelque chose qui est quand même
remarquable qui est d'avoir enclenché un
mouvement global de transition hors des
énergies fossiles l'accord pour tripler
la production des énergies renouvelables
d' ici à
2030 et de la part de l'Union
européenne une position en soutien des
solutions financière pour l'atténuation
l'adaptation et le financement voilà je
suis à votre disposition pour les
questions que vous merci madame la
ministre c'est vrai qu'on a embrassé de
de nombreux
sujets je reviens avant de donner la
parole à mes collègues juste un instant
je vous avais fait part en conclusion de
notre déb préceil en séance de mes
inquiétudes sur le budget
elle reste aussi grande malgré vos
explications on sent très bien quand
même qu' il y a des tensions qu'on n pas
de d'éléments d'éléments probants sur
sur l'avenir et sur les ressources
propres et donc qu' qu'on sait très bien
que aujourd'hui on est en phase où
effectivement on a devant nous des
dépenses conséquentes et
importantes et final
pour aboutir à des politiques qui sont
construites dans l'Union et finalement
en
face pas forcément la recette qui vient
d'autant que moi j'ai beaucoup apprécié
votre les précisions que vous avez
apporté en disant qu'il était hors de
question que les États-membres et en
particulier la France on parlait de
l'article liminaire tout à l'heure
augmente leur
contribution et que c'était c'était un
des points de discussion qui était qui
était fortement fort appuyé par par la
France ce sur quoi nous sommes d'accord
euh mais voilà euh on augmente pas les
recettes mais on sait très bien que les
grandes dépenses vont arriver notamment
les 50 milliards sur sur l'Ukraine dont
je ne suis pas convaincu aujourd'hui
qu'il soit cautionné mais à la limite
peu importe puisqu'on est sur sur un
élément géopolitique et géostratégique
mais voilà je je je reste quand même
très très dubitatif sur la façon dont
l'union va pouvoir porter euh C ces
grands enjeux budgétaires je vous le
disais quand j'ai commencé ma présidence
ici à la commission c'est un sujet qu'on
abordait à peine parce que il y avait
des discussions sur le SCFP mais on
avait pas d'inquiétude on savait que
c'était simplement un calage dans les
chapitres et pas forcément un manque de
ressources aujourd'hui on a on a
l'impression qu'on arrive vers le le
sujet manque de ressources donc ça c'est
c'est le point sur lequel je voudrais je
voudrais insister merci d'avoir fait un
point sur le Proche Orient on l'avait
pas évoqué parce qu'on n pas franchement
dans dans dans le cadre dans le cadre
européen mais on sait très bien que ce
ce genre de débat prend une grande
partie du conseil puisque les chefs
d'État sont sont réunis entre eux un
petit point peut-être parce que vous
avez parlé de de la libre circulation
euh au sein de l'Union dans le cadre du
Pacte aie l'immigration peut-être sur
Schengen savoir où on en est euh des
discussions notamment avec la Roumanie
euh qui est toujours très demandeuse mes
interlocuteurs roumains quand je les
croise m'interrogent toujours sur cette
question de de de l'intégration de la la
la Roumanie dans dans l'espace Schengen
donc peut-être prenez le temps il y a il
y a pas urgence pour y répondre mais je
voudrais pouvoir avoir aussi sur cette
question une une visibilité d'autant
d'autant qu'il y a la Moldavie derrière
dans à la porte d'entrée qui qui qui
frappe et on sait très bien que 80 % des
des moldaves sont aujourd'hui détenteurs
d'un passeport roumain donc d'un
passeport européen et que voilà quel
serait quelles seraient les les
conséquences donc voilà en ce qui en ce
qui me concerne les les les points qui
ne sont pas des questions mais qui sont
des points de de vigilance alors
Dominique de
leè merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre vous avez évoqué la question
de de la défense et de la souveraineté
européenne je dois vous dire que il me
semble qu'il va falloir qu'un jour on
sorte un
peu des ambigués et et de la sémantique
parce que moi j'y comprends plus rien
j'avais cru comprendre moi que la
défense c'était encore du domaine
national mais on joue sur les mots parce
que souscouvert de politique
industrielle et de coopération en la
matière j'aimerais savoir où se situe la
frontière entre entre ce qui relève
d'une compétence européenne et ce qui
reste d'une compétence nationale
deuxièmement toujours frappé lorsqu'on
parle
d'industrie de défense au niveau
européen qu'on n'associe pas notre
réflexion et notre débat le partenaire
essentiel qui est l'utant parce que
qu'on le veuille ou non je suis bien
obligé d'observer que nos partenaires
européens ils sont quand même assez
tentés et dans la pratique c'est la
réalité d'acheter du matériel et des
équipements qui ne sont pas européen
donc moi je trouve que le discours est
sympathique mais il va peut-être falloir
qu'à un moment donné on ouvre vraiment
les yeux et qu'on dise clairement qui
fait quoi quelle est l'alliance et
surtout qu'on élargisse le débat à la
question euh de
l'autant merci Dominique je rappelle que
Dominique de leège est rapporteur
spécial la commission des finances sur
le budget de la
défense donc il faut pas m'en vouloir
vous donc il faut pas il faut pas lui en
volloir voilà euh j'ai cinq inscrits
madame la ministre est-ce qu'on prend
les cinq et vous répondez globalement ou
est-ce que vous préférez par
séquence allez on y va euh merci pour
ces questions euh pour le CFP je pense
qu'il y a deux choses il y a la révision
à mi-parcours d'un budget qui est
forcément bouleversé et par la la guerre
en Ukraine et par l'inflation qui
évidemment n'était pas prévue quand on a
fait ce budget européen pour C ans
d'Union Européenne donc la
l'augmentation de budget qu' a demandé
la Commission européenne à
miparcours comme vous savez était juste
beaucoup trop pour la plupart des
États-membres sa position de négociation
de départ était n'a convenu à personne
il faut il faut quand même le dire et ce
que nous avons demandé et sur à tous
c'est à la fois des redéploiements là où
bien sûr il restait des poches et à la
fois une modération notamment dans les
hausses de fonctionnement les salaires
de fonctionnaires l'augmentation du
nombre de fonctionnaires quand tous les
États-membres sont en train d'essayer de
d'ajuster leurs finances publiques donc
où est-ce qu'on en est aujourd'hui en
fait il y
a il y a eu un une grande discussion
avec une pour le coup une vraie revue à
la baisse de ce que demandait la
Commission européenne euh et puis et
puis la discussion sur le financement de
l'Ukraine dans la durée donc on
a on a à peu près gelé donc ça veut dire
que ça a été négocié et que ça sera
repris en l'état le 1er février tout ce
qui est qui ne concerne pas la les 50
milliards pour l'Ukraine qui sont à part
et ce qu'on a négocié je crois tout le
monde
avait confiance qu'on puisse
parfaitement arriver à
l'entériner euh au conseil du 1er
février il faut se rappeler la position
de la Hongrie quand elle est arrivée au
Conseil qui était de dire non à
tout et qui a cédé donc qui s'est
abstenu sur sur l'ouverture des
négociations à l'Ukraine qui était ce
qui était le plus important pour
l'Ukraine donc je crois que ça aurait
été très difficile de d'obtenir de de la
Hongrie qui qui était déjà qui s'était
déjà partiellement dédit d'aller encore
plus loin d'où cette nécessité je vous
l'ai dit les mauvaises langues disent
que ça a coûté 10 milliards à l'Union
non alors ça je pense que c'est une
énorme maladresse vous savez que la h la
Hongrie a remis sa réforme de la justice
en avril 2023 normalement la Commission
a 90 jours pour examiner cette réforme
et je pense qu'elle aurait pu aller un
peu plus vite pour donner son rendu et
effectivement libérer l'argent qui été
retenu à cause de cette réforme puisque
la réforme a été fait que c'est un peu
mal la droit de faire ça deux ou TR
jours avant le Conseil puisque ça ouvre
la porte à ce type
de de pensée qui vient bien évidemment
naturellement euh sur les 50 milliards
sur 4 ans prévus pour l'Ukraine je vous
cache pas que ça sera beaucoup plus
difficile je je pense qu'on arrivera à
un compromis probablement en s'engageant
sur un an ce qui sera déjà bien et qui
sera significatif euh à nouveau pas du
tout pour des dissensions entre les 2
tête he mais toujours pour la même
raison qui est qui est la Hongrie mais
si on arrive à continuer à travailler
ensemble comme ça je je pense que
franchement c'est bien je vous rappelle
que les États-Unis eux sont totalement
bloqués sur le
sujet sur
Schengen et la et la Roumanie il y a
deux pays qui s'occupent qui s'opposent
à l'ouverture de Schengen largement pour
des questions
électoralistes ce qui n'arrive jamais
chez nous hein jamais euh et qui donc
bloque en prévision des perspectives
européennes notamment un comme vous le
savez qui est qui est un de leurs
voisins nous on continue d'avancer de
pousser pour ça euh je crois que le
c'est le Luxembourg le 2e c'était ça ou
c'était
l'riche
euh mais en tous les cas
ouais c'est ça les Néerlandais sont
revenus un peu là-dessus bon maintenant
on a le nouveau gouvernement qui a
risque de prendre un peu de temps à
former ce ce qui n'est peut-être pas si
mal et et pour pour l'Autriche je pense
que c'est c'est un tout petit peu
compliqué mais ils avaient demandé des
statistiques des mesures régulières de
ce qui se passait à leur frontières et
et les la Roumanie est maintenant en
mesure de de fournir certaines de ses
données donc on pense qu'on peut arriver
à débloquer les choses petit à petit
puis la Bulgarie avait un point qui
était de dire queil valait mieux mettre
les agents de contrôle au frontières aux
frontières extérieur de l'Union
européenne plutôt que à l'intérieur des
frontières de l'Union européenne donc on
a on avance
doucement sur la défense monsieur le
sénateur je crois qu'il y
a il y a trois principes
cardinaux pour nous il est évident que
les 27 ne font pas assez sur la défense
les dividendes de la pai a aussi voulu
dire un recul en matière de capacité de
production
industrielle et ça pour le coup la la
guerre de de la Russie en Ukraine le
montre et le montre un peu cruellement
donc on a besoin de reconstruire une
capacité de production industrielle
européenne en Europe la deuxième chose
et vous avez raison l'idée n'est pas de
s'affranchir de l'OTAN ni de le faire
contre l'OTAN l'idée est d'être un
pilier fort de
l'UTAN mais le troisième point et vous
le connaissez comme moi c'est
les incertitudes qui sont liées aux
élections américaines et qui pourrai
faire que nombre de pays que que nous
nous retrouvions un peu seul avec un
candidat qui comme vous le savez ne
s'est jamais caché du mépris qu'il a
pour l'utant et voir qu'il pourrait s'en
détourner donc l'idée est pas du tout
d'aller contre l' temp l'idée est de
renforcer nos capacités de production
pour que nous soyons plus fort ensemble
et que ça contribue mieux aussi à à
l'OTAN après ça pose deux sujets que
trois sujets que vous avez évoqué la
première c'est la capacité
d'investissement et ce qu'on met en
commun si on met en commun de quoi
produire des munitions ce qui ne met pas
en danger notre souveraineté nous
Français ce que nous demandons c'est que
on les produise en Europe parce que si
c'est de l'argent des contribuables
européens il faut qu'il aille dans la
construction de matériel européen et
d'une capacité de production européenne
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose oui beaucoup de pays européens
effectivement continue d'acheter des F35
et du matériel américain je vous
rappelle que sur ce genre de mat
matériel il y a une carte américaine qui
fait qu'il contrôle quand vous les
utilisez et comment vous les utilisez
donc il y a une vraie question de
souveraineté
maintenant c'est pour ça que nous nous
appuyons pour développer en européen des
alternatives à nouveau pas contre mais
pour pouvoir être maître et souverain
quand nous décidons d'utiliser du
matériel maintenant on le sait ça va
prendre du temps et et mais il faut
qu'on le fasse maintenant et on va être
très vigilant sur la stratégie de
défense qui est produite par la
commission pour que ça respecte notre
souveraineté notre capacité à faire des
choses mais aussi que ce soit européen
le dernier sujet quand vous parlez de
souveraineté à raison nous voulons
rester une
puissance c'est la somme puissance
nucléaire de l'Union européenne déjà
avec un consiège au Conseil de sécurité
d'u et c'est absolument pas remis en
cause et ensuite nous voulons
être souverain dans notre décision de ce
qu'on exporte comme matériel militaire
et à qui on l'exporte il est évident
qu'il faut en exporter pour pour pouvoir
avoir une industrie qui qui croit mais
il est évident aussi qu'on ne veut pas
se faire empêcher par d'autres qui ne
voudrai pas exporter ce que nous
produisons ni se faire imposer la façon
dont nous le faisons j'espère que j'ai
répondu à vos
inquiétudes merci alors Jacques ferern
et se prépare Florence batrix conta
alors merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre trois questions sur le
proche orient
oui
les tous les États de l'Union européenne
sont sont d'accord sur la solution à
deux états
euh ceci dit c'est plutôt je dirais une
position de principe depuis euh on peut
remonter jusqu'à la résolution
historique de l'ONU euh mais on sent pas
vraiment une ligne stratégique visible
donc quel chemin ouvrir défricher pour
avancer dans ce sens quelle initiative
de l'Union quel moyen pour peser en ce
sens en incitant Israël à pas persister
vers le pire et en donnant des
perspectives à ceux il y en a des
Palestiniens qui peuvent être des
acteurs majeurs dans une telle
perspective
sur l'Ukraine la Moldavie oui
l'ouverture des des négociations pour
leur adhésion est un signal très positif
qui envoyé à ces deux pays c'est aussi
un signal à la Russie bien sûr alors
heureusement le en quelque sorte c'est
le leadership allemand si j'ai bien
compris qui a réussi à convaincre Victor
Orban de de quitter la salle et ainsi
permettre aux 26 dirigeants européens de
voter à l'unanimité l'ouverture des
négociations
d'adhésion donc c'est une stratégie
qu'on doit essentiellement à Olaf Scholz
euh je m'interroge un peu sur le rôle
joué joué par la France sur le le
soutien financier à à l'Ukraine
euh la France quand on regarde les les
classements le classement pointe en 13e
position derrière l'Allemagne les
États-Unis le Royaume-Uni et et même
derrière la Pologne quand on voit le le
graphique en barre on l'a vu dans la
presse sur les réseaux
sociaux la barre française c'est plus un
point qu'une barre voilà donc on
s'interroge aussi là-dessus on pourrait
faire politiquement et économiquement
mieux et et face au au vous avez parler
de de large unanimité de l'Union
européenne sur l'aide à l'Ukraine bon
dans la perspective du du cadre
financier pluriannuel large mais pas
encore total le le vetau de la Hongrie
qui à mon sens bloque
toujours quelle position défendre au
conseil pour arriver à surmonter cela et
un dernier point si je ve pas être trop
long sur la question de la directive des
sur les violences sexistes et sexuelles
euh on a ét quand même un peu
décontenancé de voir la France s'allié à
la Pologne et à la Hongrie pour exclure
le viol de la directive avec des
arguments techniques compliqué arguments
qui ont d'ailleurs été largement balayés
par les députés européens
Renaissance hein qui ont écrit une
tribune à ce sujet donc les négociations
on pas pu aboutir sont désormais
repoussé euh est-ce que la France va
persister sur sa position si
contestée Florence blatrix conta et se
prépare à Mel gaaker puis Mathilde
Olivier on prendra les les quatre si ça
vous
dérange merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre donc avec ma collègue
Christine Lavarde ce matin nous avons
présenté une proposition de résolution
européenne sur la réforme du PACT de
stabilité et de croissance en soutien à
la position française nous insistons
dans notre proposition sur la nécessité
de voir aboutir la réforme avant les
échéances européennes nous saluons les
avancées de l'accord obtenu hier qui
plaide euh on l'espère pour un
calendrier tenu avant les élections euh
nous apportons tout notre soutien
vraiment au principe de différenciation
d'appropriation que nous avait exposé le
ministre Bruno Le Maire même si nous
regrettons que finalement les clauses de
sauvegarde qui ont pu être concédées au
frugo viennent amoindrir la portée de
ces deux principes donc la clause de
sauvegarde du volet correctif a été
conservée à 0,5 points du PIB par an
quand le déficit dépasse les 3 % donc
nous regrettons bien entendu que la
proposition
[Musique]
euh exclut finalement les investissement
vert du calcul de ce 0,5 points de PIB
nous avions défendu cela dans notre
PPRE et suite à cet accord la France
estime qu'elle a été entendue avec la
prise en compte de l'augmentation de la
charge de la dette en sur 2025 2026-
2027 l'utilisation du terme prise en
compte nous
paraît néanmoins relativement flou
est-ce que vous pouvez finalement nous
expliquer les les contours de cette
prise en compte euh de l'augmentation de
la charge de la dette euh ma deuxième
question portera sur la révision du
cadre financier pluri-annuel pour lequel
vous nous avez indiqué qu'un accord
était très proche je partage les
préoccupations de du président
Rapin là encore nous regrettons la
baisse du niveau d'ambition par rapport
à la proposition de la Commission qui
était de 66 milliards est-ce que le
beaucoup trop que vous nous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure n'est pas nécessaire
néanmoins pour répondre aux nouveaux
défis qui font auxquels nous devons
faire face et est-ce que la piste de
nouvelles ressources propres avance
réellement et euh plus précisément cette
baisse d'ampleur cela a déjà été dit
impliquera des redéploiement de
politique européennees pouvez-vous nous
indiquer si la France sera concernée et
pour quelle politique je vous
remercie merci Monsieur le le le
président ma dernière phase I ma
dernière question concerne le
redéploiement des politiques européennes
est-ce que la France est concernée pour
quel type de
politique merci merci monsieur le
président madame la
ministre je vais commencer tout d'abord
par saluer la décision bien sûr de de
l'Union européenne d'ouvrir les
négociations d'
avec l'Ukraine une décision qui était
bien sûr attendue de tous et qui
rappelle bien sûr notre soutien sans
sans ambiguité pour pour l'Ukraine mais
je souhaite justement sur ce sujet
m'arrêter sur ses conséquences sur les
conséquences de l'adhésion en fait de de
de
l'Ukraine sujet qui en fait n'est pas
nouveau mais qui est au combien
essentiel euh notamment pour notre
souveraineté
agricole notre souveraineté alimentaire
je parle en fait des conséquences de
cette adhésion sur le secteur de
l'agriculture française et de
l'agriculture européenne pourquoi parce
que déstabiliser notre agriculture
clairement c'est déstabiliser notre
indépendance alimentaire en terme de
conséquence l'Ukraine deviendrait le
plus gros producteur agricole ce qui
bien
sûr renforcerait hein notre puissance
nos capacités exportatrices qui est une
bonne chose par contre l'impact euh
notamment sur la PAC euh notamment sur
les aides de la PAC euh pour nos
agriculteurs et sur les politiques
agricoles des des États-membres euh est
loin loin d'être négligeable donc il
faudra euh probablement euh repenser euh
la PAC et nécessairement euh et encore
une fois c'est c'est un sujet qui avait
été d'ailleurs abordé hein précédemment
mais euh les distorsions de concurrence
entre les pays euh entre ent les États
les états- membres donc est-ce que vous
pourriez nous éclairer sur l'état de vos
réflexions sur le sujet et surtout ce
que vous envisagez également à ce sujet
puis une deuxième question en fait je
rebondis
sur sur ce que vous avez évoqué
notamment les investissement conséquents
en matière de transition écologique qui
nous attendent je suis avec d'ailleurs
le président
sénateur sénatrice pardon donc nous
sommes sénateurs du du pas decalis et
cuide du soutien de l'Union européenne
face aux conséquences des catastrophes
climatiques que subissent régulièrement
nos territoire bien sûr ici en France
mais bien sûr aussi ailleurs catastrophe
qui vous n'êtes pas sans savoir vous
bien sûr vous êtes au sujet de ce que
nous avons vécu et surtout de ce que ce
que nous vivons et ce qui nous attend en
terme de besoins pour notre
reconstruction évidemment je pose cette
question pour notre territoire des Haut-
de France du Pas de Calais mais bien sûr
sur tous les territoires de l'Union
européenne qui seront amenés
malheureusement à subir de plus en plus
ce genre de situation je vous remercie
Mathilde merci monsieur le Président euh
madame la ministre je vais revenir sur
sur le PACT européen sur la migration et
l'asile qui a arrivé en parallèle du
texte désolant pour dire peu au niveau
français euh revenir sur votre analyse
du texte qui a été adopté au niveau
européen euh à la fois sur euh enfin sur
certain nombre de mesures qui ont qui
ont été adoptées sur le filtrage à
l'arrivée en fonction de la nationalité
du pays d'arrivée qui pourrait
s'apparenter à un triage sur la
privation de liberté à l'arrivée des
personnes qui demandent l'asile aussi
sur le fichage qui sera qui est prévu
dès l'enfance puisque il pourra
commencer à 6 ans avec prise d'empreinte
digitale bon voilà j' je je je fais
cours et j'en parle que je parle que de
certaines de ces mesures mais on voit
qu'il y en a un certain nombre qui se
pose en fau de des principes
fondamentaux du droit d'asile euh et
notamment le fait que c'est bien une
approche individuelle et une
appréciation individuelle qui doit
être adoptée pour définir les droits
d'asile des personnes exilé qui le
demande euh alors comment comment s'est
positionné la France dans ses
négociations et quelle est votre analyse
du texte finalement adopté au niveau
européen
merci beaucoup pour toutes ces questions
puis vous êtes extrêmement bien
coordonné car vous ne vous recoup pas du
tout je suis très
impressionnée al là
franchement je vois
ça alors sur la
solution de état comme vous savez la
France a toujours porté cette voix que
c'était la la seule façon d'arriver à la
paix dans la région de de d'assurer à
Israël son droit à la sécurité et puis
en même temps d'assurer aux Palestiniens
leur droit à un
état c'est vrai que tous les pays ne
reconnaissent pas l'état
palestinien et je crois qu'il faut aussi
amener Israël à comprendre qu'un État
palestinien sera un facteur de sécurité
pour eux c'était le sens de la tribune
de la ministre Colona le 22 octobre dans
pardon pas de son Inter dans la tribune
euh et ce que nous essayons de faire en
ce moment c'est de voir avec nos
partenaires quand est-ce qu'il est le
plus utile de remettre ça sur la table
dans le cadre de de la relance du
processus de paix
euh sur
euh l'Ukraine et la Moldavie et le rôle
joué par Olaf Scholz j'ai apprécié le
côté taquin de votre question mais comme
vous savez tout tout toutes
ces tous ces conseils quand il y a des
blocages en fait se tiennent aussi des
réunions en marge en ccle restreint
notamment avec la présidente de la
commission le président du
Conseil l'Allemagne la France l'Italie
parfois les Pays-Bas et évidemment la
Hongrie et il y a eu beaucoup de travail
préparatoire à la tenue du conseil de
façon plus formelle ici je crois que
c'était important d'amener Victor Orban
à comprendre qu'il ne pouvait pas
s'opposer à à cette à cette décision et
je pense que le le fait de se retrouver
isolé joue un un rôle euh puissant dans
dans dans son sa décision de ne pas
s'opposer euh je ce qui ce qu' doit
ensuite évidemment défendre en
retournant chez lui je voudrais aussi
rappeler le rôle de la France
qui dès la guerre dès l'invasion de
l'Ukraine par la Russie a parleré de
perspective européenne de l'Ukraine qui
a donné le statut de candidat à
l'Ukraine sous présidence française de
l'Union européenne et puis maintenant
qui participe à l'ouverture des
négociations en ce qui concerne l'aide
financière à l'Ukraine c'était l'aide
financière dont vous vouliez me
parler je je crois pas que nous ayons
de que nous ayons de de complexes à
avoir et je je je crois que vraiment on
prend toute notre part dans dans cet
effort d'abord on est le deuxèe pays
contributeur au budget de la facilité
européenne de paix qui fournit les
armements à Kief nous avons contribué à
hauteur de 1,2 milliards ce qui
représente plus de 18 % du budget total
qui est de 6,5 milliards nous formons
aussi des des soldats Ukrainiens 5000
sur les 30000 soldats qui sont formés en
Europe et puis à nouveau et on en
parlait avec avec le sénateur de l'ège
c'est la France qui a lancé la création
d'instruments européens pour renforcer
les industries de défense et pour
pouvoir aider les Ukrainiens sur la
durée donc je crois qu'on est assez noit
dans nos bottes sur ce
sujet sur le viol alors ça s'inscrit
dans un texte qui comme vous savez est
beaucoup plus large de violente de
violence faite aux femmes texte dans
lequel nous voulons voir préserver des
mesures notamment celles qui sont contre
la mutilation des organes génitaux et
d'autres donc je vous passe les détails
peu amainant
euh le problème n'est pas la France qui
a effectivement sa définition
elle du consentement qui se caractérise
par la surprise la menace la violence et
la contrainte et qui porte la charge de
la preuve de se dédire de ça sur sur la
personne qui commet ses actes mais le
problème que nous avons il est avec la
Bulgarie avec la Hongrie avec la
Lituanie avec la République tchèque qui
n'ont tous et la Slovaquie d'ailleurs
qui tous ces pays n'ont pas signé la
convention d'Istanbul contrairement à la
France et contrairement à l'Union
européenne convention d'Istanbul qui
parle aussi du consentement donc quel
nous on a une définition à la fois qui
repose sur la culpabilité de l'agresseur
et sur la consentement de la personne
agressée avec la convention d'istanbou
donc ce à quoi nous pouss son c'est que
ces cinq pays se rapprochent de la
convention d'Istanbul ce qui nous permet
effectivement après je vais pas rentrer
dans les détails technique de on va
mettre un considérant parce que comme ça
on peut rappeler les choses mais c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment notre sujet
aujourd'hui je rappelle aussi que il a
l'Allemagne qui est sur notre position
euh sur
euh euh sur le PACT de stabilité et de
croissance effectivement je crois que
c'est un accord qui est qui est tout à
fait honorable d'abord parce qu'il
rassemble des positions qui sont assez
éloignées et ensuite parce qu'il il
reprend vraiment nos euh nos les piliers
sur lesquels nous voulions insister
d'abord le fait de l'appropriation comme
vous l'avez souligné qui je crois est
très important pour tenir compte de la
situation spécifique des états ensuite
de permettre des investissements à la
fois vert à la fois dans le numérique à
la fois dans la défense puisque les
période sur lesquelles on doit ajuster
les finances publiques vont pouvoir
varier avec les investissements et les
réformes qui sont fait et
ensuite alors je je je suis sûr de ce
que je vais vous dire qu' a 95 % donc je
reviendrai sur les 5 % mais on on était
on négociait que suivant le niveau de la
charge de la dette on puiss celui-ci on
puisse aussi ajuster l'ajustement par 02
ou 03 points de façon à ce que quand les
taux explosent on ne ça n'aboutisse pas
à des des conditions
excessivement
restrictives mais je vous le confirmerai
en bilatéral si cela vous va en tout cas
c'était vraiment quelque chose auquel on
tenait même si on peut se dire que la
plupart des prévisionnistes maintenant
sont plus sur un ralentissement des taux
d'intérêt que que sur une une hausse il
y a effectivement eu des redéploiement
d'abord de poches qui en général ont pas
été complètement utilisé c'est la
première des choses sur laquelle nous
avons insisté euh et nous nous avons
insisté pour préserver nos priorités
principales qui étit migration Ukraine
et ce fond de souveraineté qui nous
paraît important si on veut continuer de
recréer de l'emploi dans tous les
territoires euh
ensuite sur sur les conséquences d'un
élargissement j'entends complètement ces
questions euh et je pense que et je le
disais en arrivant ici à votre collègue
c'est quelque chose sur lequel nous
devons travailler ensemble pour
expliquer comment ça se passe en
pratique la période moyenne nécessaire
pour accéder à l'Union européenne elle
va de 8 à 15 et parfois même 24 ans pour
la Macédoine et ils y sont toujours pas
donc on parle d'un processus sur le
temps long il est dans notre intérêt de
garder ces pays ancrés chez nous pour
qu'il ne dérive pas vers la Russie la
Chine ou d'autres pays pamè et on voit
tellement les tentatives de ilisation
notamment dans les Balcans occidentaux
que vous connaissez bien donc l'idée
c'est que il se réfore pour atteindre
nos standards dans matière d'état de
droit mais aussi économique social
environnemental ce qui va prendre du
temps là on est dans la première phase
les prochaines étapes seront celles de
la formation du cadre des négociations
que l'on espèra en mars mais qui
pourrait être à la fin du premier
semestre et qui est à ce moment-là où on
va pouvoir fixer ce qu'on exige deeux en
matière agricole en matière économique
en matière sociale en matière
environnementale tout toutes ces toutes
ces politiques publiques sur lesquelles
ils vont devoir se réformer puisque là
on est sur l'état de droit avant de
passer à l'étape suivante et une fois
qu'on aura fixé ce cadre de négociation
qui prend du temps s'ouvriront les
processur d'ouverture des négociations
avec une conférence intergouvernementale
et là c'est un processus de 5 10 15 ou
20 ans suivant les efforts qui sont
faits donc vraiment je pense qu'il faut
le répéter
on na pas des nouveaux pays de main mais
après c'est aussi dans notre intérêt qu'
continue d'être motivés et qu'ils
avancent sur le chemin de l'adhésion et
dans le même temps nous devons réformer
nos politiques on vient de parler de
défense comme jamais vous en avez parlé
il y a 3 ans et donc évidemment nous
devons nous assurer que il y ait une
construction qui respecte nos
souverainetés
respectiv qui et les financements qui
vont derrière et la gouvernance qui va
derrière et ça aussi ça va prendre
beaucoup de temps puisque on aura la
feuille de route à la fin de la première
moitié de 2024 et ensuite vous savez
très bien que la seconde moitié 2024 va
être occupée à construire la Commission
et cetera donc c'est quelque chose qu'on
va déjà commencer en 2025 à priori vos
suggggestion les rapports toutes les
conférences que vous pouvez faire seront
évidemment très utiles mais je crois
qu'on est vraiment dans un changement de
logiciel et parfois avec des cercles qui
seront peut-être plus concentrés ça
existe avec l'euro donc c'est pas non
plus un un gros mot euh de dire ça
peut-être un dernier mot sur
l'agriculture pour rappeler par exemple
concrètement quand l'Espagne a rejoint
l'Union européenne euh on lui a demandé
après le processus d'adhésion donc quand
elle est devenue État membre de l'Union
européenne on a demander une période de
transition de 10 ans pour les produits
agricoles euh à nouveau dans l'optique
de protéger euh notre agriculture euh
existante et puis vous pouvez euh quand
on écoute les 27 c'est assez intéressant
de voir les les différents points de vue
certains pays sont persuadés que comme
les exploitations agricoes ukrainiennes
sont très grande vu la définition
d'impac aujourd'hui elles auraient droit
à rien voilà donc il faut vraiment je
pense qu'on prenne le temps de réfléchir
et de et de réformer ça sur le fond de
solidarité de l'Union européenne qui je
crois est important et sur lequel nous
sommes en train de travailler ensemble
je vais en profiter pour pour
passer un petit un petit appel comme
vous savez pour l'instant nous avons
prévenu la Commission européenne pour
les haut fr c'est l' Haut- de France oui
pour les haut de France que nous
voulions avoir recours fsue suite au aux
inodations donc là nous sommes en train
de travailler au contré des services
déconcentrés pour réaliser le dossier de
demande de l'utilisation du FSU le plus
rapidement possible vous savez que nous
avons un délai de 10 semaines donc donc
si vous pouvez nous aider à insister
auprès des services déconcentrés de
d'accélérer ça serait ça serait
formidable puisqu'on a besoin d'avoir un
bilan des montants à à demander en en
résultat de des dégâts qui ont été
causés par les intempéries puis après
quand on regarde sur le moyen terme il y
a nous il y a bien sur eu la Slovénie
aussi cet été donc on est en train de
réfléchir à comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait faire évoluer et adapter ce FSU
pour aller pour une meilleure adaptation
et meilleure réponse aux catastrophe
Natur madame la ministre je me permets
sur le fsue en fait effectivement et et
vous venez de répondre je pense
partiellement à la question qu'on se
pose c'est entre le fait que l'État
membre sollicite le FSU le fsue et le
fait de pouvoir évaluer les dépenses
dont on sait que le FSU n'est déclenché
qu'en fonction du montant des dépenses
c'est un vrai sujet parce
que je comprends par vos propos que que
la simple annonce qu'on veut déclencher
le FSU ne suffit pas le délai des 10
semaines c'est qu'on doit avoir rendu le
montant des travaux dans les 10 semaines
sauf madame la ministre qu'aujourd'hui
dans ce cadre particulier des
inondations il y a encore des
territoires qui sont inondés et sur
lesquels tant que l'eau n'est pas parti
c'est un détail technique je suis désolé
dans une commission comme la nôre de de
l'évoquer mais c'est la réalité du
terrain c'est-à-dire que ne sera que par
exemple les travaux sur les lignes de
chemin de
fer aujourd'hui on est encore incapable
de les évaluer puisqu'ils sont pas fait
et que les interventions importantes ne
peuvent pas se faire tant que le terrain
n'est pas asséché donc j'ai vu et j'ai à
peu près estimé qu'il fallait déclarer
pour déclencher le fond en haut de
France et dans le pas decaléis en
particulier 1 milliard 7 de travaux à
l'échelle de la région ce qui est quand
même énorme
donc voilà je pense que ce mécanisme est
intéressant c'est un mécanisme de
solidarité mais que dans l'application
pratique c'est impossible il y a encore
des territoires où les routes se lèvent
parce que les nappes ne sont pas
redescendues donc en 10 semaines il est
incap on est incapable de faire une
évaluation correcte et on sait très bien
que l'évaluation de l'évaluation
correcte va dépendre le montant
d'aide merci oui c'est pour ça que deux
choses la première c'est pour ça qu'on
est en train de regarder parce que la
Slovénie avait eu aussi le même type de
problème et vous savez que si un pays en
a ça ne suffit pas à déclencher quelque
chose mais comme on est plusieurs on
peut en discuter on regarde aussi dans
l' France ce qui se passe du côté de la
frontière avec la
Belgique pour ça mais si s'il y a
quelque chose de spécifique à mon avis
il faut qu'on se parle en bilatéral pour
qu'on prévienne la Commission et qu'on
essaie de trouver une solution qui soit
qui soit mutuellement bénéfique
absolument
merci
pardon oui oui excusez-moi c'est parce
qu'il faut que je change de papier
oui oui sur le pacte asile
immigration franchement vu les positions
des différents pays du Parlement je
pense qu'on a trouvé un un un compromis
et une solution assez complète dont on
peut tous
être assez content et assez fier c'est
ça fait 10 ans que ça
patine et ça fait et et entre des
attitudes parfois très dur de certains
pays je me souviens vous n'étiez pas
encore là mais nous en avions parlé en
commission de m'être retrouvé avec un
groupe de C pays que je citeraiis pas
qui voulait construire des murs des
marbelet et des systèmes assez
impressionnants et sur lesquels on avait
dû expliquer que la position française
c'était pas de brique et pas de mortier
et donc pas de mur mais voilà je crois
qu'il faut regarder un peu d'où on
vient sur le filtrage et la mesure
précise que vous évoquez l'idée elle est
en fait de on a deux types de personnes
qui arrivent enfin au moins de type de
personnes qui arrivent sur aux
frontières de l'Union européenne des
demandeurs d'asile qui viennent de pays
où ils sont menacés pour les résions de
réion de religion de de sexe de de
guerre de tout ce que vous connaissez et
des personnes qui choisissent cette
route comme une route de migration
économique donc ce qui se passe c'est
qu'en général ils viennent euh et ils se
font immanquablement euh refouler et
retourner dans leur pays et on les
connaît ces pays parce qu'on a le taux
de retour par nationalité donc il s'agit
pas d'un filtrage en fonction des
nationalités il s'agit de voir que pour
ceux qui en fait o le tout de retour est
à peu près de 80 % à la frontière on va
faire une procédure accélérée et leur
dire leur demander de passer par la loi
de par la route de la migration
économique aussi parce que les capacités
de traitement des vrais demande d'asile
sont engorgé et et c'est un problème par
la migration économique donc il s'agit
de mieux faire et de faire que chacun
puisse venir par la voix qui est la
meilleure pour pour la sienne vous avez
parlé de fichage en fait quand les
personnes arrivent on les enregistre ce
qui est normal on fait les vérifications
de tests sanitaires beaucoup sont
malades il faut les soigner de test
sécuritaire vous connaissez le contexte
je vais pas le rappeler et ensuite
évidemment de traiter la demande
beaucoup plus vite d'ailleurs avec ce
système que ce qui était fait avant ce
qui je pense est beaucoup plus humain
euh quand vous parlez de fichage c'est
pour les familles les mineurs non
accompagnés ont été exclus dans la
version du PCT asile migration donc on
fait aussi attention à essayer de de
trouver des équilibres et puis je crois
qu' a
des euh il y a des il y a des avan c'est
notamment en matière de conseil
juridique gratuit de mieux accompagner
les personnes de de de faire attention
aussi où on met les familles dans
l'attente d'une demande de de demande
d'asile donc vraiment d'essayer de
trouver cet équilibre et je crois que la
solidarité entre les 27 qui comme vous
savez était loin d'être évident
puisqu'on a eu des gros
blocages de la Hongrie de nouveau et de
la Pologne on espère que ça va changer
avec le nouveau
gouvernement ce qu'on fait et et plutôt
bien je crois
MERCI MERCI madame la ministre de deux
points d'information qui ont un lien
direct avec ce qu'on a évoqué ce matin
nous nous recevrons le commissaire
Thierry
Breton courant courant janvier justement
pour les questions d'industrie et et
d'industrie militaire en particulier et
puis je vous lance une invitation comme
ça mais on va la formaliser euh nous
allons faire une réunion euh
avec les ambassadeurs des 27 ici au
Sénat sur l'élargissement et sur la la
position de chaque état-membre pour
essayer de nous éclairer qui sera suivi
d'un petit cocktail parce que j'avais
commencé à prendre l'habitude de les
recevoir tous à l'occasion de la
nouvelle année mais à cette occasion
nous nous vous inviterons à l'issue de
cette réunion parce que je pense que ça
peut être aussi intéressant d'avoir la
vie de nos ambassadeurs ici en France et
qui sont porte-parole finalement de le
leurs états et surtout quand ils peuvent
s'exprimer tous
ensemble merci beaucoup avec grand
plaisir vous verrez que il faut les
pousser pour réformer les politiques de
l'Union européenne puis même si c'est
dans les conclusions du Conseil à chaque
fois une petite frilosité chez certains
mais je serais curieuse d'avoir votre
vos impressions à la suite de cette
discussion merci beaucoup en tout cas
puis bonne bonne fin d'année et je sais
qu'elle a été très très chargée
pour vous notamment avec le conseil mais
aussi euh avec votre petit séjour dans
les
Balcans
voilà merci
merci